le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
démarrer une activité n'est pas toujours
facile depuis mai 2016 le département a
mis en place le tage tremplin pour
l'activité des jeunes en plus d'une aide
financière de 8000 euros maximum
il offre un accompagnement administratif
et juridique rencontre avec deux jeunes
créateurs d'entreprise
idriss et geoffrey qui nous parlent de
leur parcours
[Musique]
alors que en est-on inspection de
routine pour idriss aucun détail ne doit
lui échapper on est spécialisée en fait
dans la rénovation et protection
automobile donc à connaître des tags
c'était était en anglais signifie en
fait de la préparation esthétique
automobile c'est une méthodologie en
fait de travail précise et minutieuse
on applique un futur véhicule de façon à
le restaurer et à leurs maîtres comme
neige avant de se consacrer à sa passion
les jeunes hommes a travaillé pendant
cinq ans dans une société de rénovation
en bâtiment
je crée l'intimité fin 2016 j'ai
découvert grâce à un ami donc en fait
tous les deux étaient passionnés de par
l'automobile en fait et on s'amusait le
week-end
le nouvel tu peux les voitures de nos
amis par plaisir pour mêler l'utile à
l'agréable
le jeune homme a décidé de créer sa
propre entreprise mais il n'est pas
toujours facile de démarrer une activité
sans trésorerie est entendu en tant que
jeune entrepreneur on convient aura
droit à cet honneur avec le département
de la réunion
donc je suis tombé sur le talent fait le
tremplin des deux jeunes de talent est
l'otage avait pu avoir la somme de 8000
euros pour démarrer l'activité donc
grâce à cette aide du pianiste iran fait
à la base
le matériel professionnel en plus de la
subvention offert par le tage le
département propose également un
accompagnement pour les jeunes
entrepreneurs est vrai que c'est
compliqué la première fois lorsqu'on se
lancent dans l'entrepreunariat mais
après faut savoir s'entourer des bonnes
personnes
moi j'ai pu bénéficier de
d'un soutien au niveau de la bonne
gestion et de débordements donc
bénéficier d'une formation avec la
chambre des métiers de l'artisanat
dans le cas de
de la subvention du tage en fait donc sa
maman après à peine un an et demi de
création idriss a su se frayer une place
sur le marché du détail
il prévoit d'embaucher un quatrième
employés d'ici la fin de l'année
de l'autre côté de l'île un tout autre
parcours
[Musique]
ça me rend fou
à saint pierre geoffrey lui a repris une
pizzeria il ya quelques mois c'est grâce
à mon ancien
ancien employeur elle m'a permis de
reprendre justement l'entreprise où je
bossais déjà depuis 5 ans donc il m'a
fait une opportunité je les saisies
pourtant rien de l'ue destiné à cette
fonction est parti sur une suis parti en
staps je vais faire j'ai fait un bac
général à aucun moment je me doutais que
j'allais reprendre alors on prend les
affaires et devenir charge en corrèze
comme idriss les génomes s'est tourné
vers 8h pour pouvoir se lancer au plus
vite dans la devanture du tage m'a
permis surtout d'investir justement au
pouvoir dans de l'immobilier surtout
dans le matériel neuf ça m'a permis
aussi surtout de développer l'entreprise
aussi pour la livraison avec un scooter
neuf
ça m'a vraiment permis d'avoir tout de
suite un pied à terre dans l'entreprise
et d'avoir de me lancer directement sont
allés faire un prêt à la banque où
puiser dans les réseaux dans les
ressources personnelles
le champ des métiers est vraiment ouvert
lhc de 18 à 25 voix 32 ans
donc vous voyez qu'il ya un champ du
possible qui est très large
on incite les jeunes qui ont des projets
vraiment de se dire que c'est possible
on a une jeunesse une jeunesse qui a
envie et jeunesse qui portent des
projets et c'est important pour le
département d'accompagner cette jeunesse
dynamique
[Musique]
le tremplin pour l'activité des jeunes a
été créé en 2016 pour les jeunes de 20 à
30 ans à la recherche d'une insertion
sociale et professionnelle attribué
après signature d'un contrat
d'accompagnement au projet d'entreprise
ces api l'aide financière d'un montant
de 8000 euros maximum permet de couvrir
les frais liés à la création
d'entreprise ou au démarrage de
l'activité
le dispositif offre également un
accompagnement administratif et
juridique aux porteurs de projets pour
plus d'information vous pouvez composer
le numéro vert 0 800 800 000 ou rendez
vous sur le site du département aux
trois double de points d'écart te ment 9
7 4 points est faire lien social
accompagne le réunionnais pour la
mobilité
je m'appelle ligne des als je viens de
la réunion la possession exactement je
suis manager au cirque au parc astérix
et j'ai 37 ans j'irai la préparation les
op le planning régler les conflits ou
ici en même temps j'avais démissionné en
fait vraiment on oriente et en métropole
à la réunion parce qu'elle a raison
c'est bien ces petits aussi donc moi je
voulais vraiment changer voit autre
chose faire plus de couleurs qui
m'intéressait le plus la soif
d'apprendre postuler au hasard vraiment
avec l'oc norme c'est un jour sur
ordinateur je ne savais même pas ce tte
quoi vraiment la base d'une assistant
personnellement pour les années je sais
pas encore ce qu ce trait nomades qui
dit que tu attends sheen brooke taylor
où on sait jamais le web fait
heureusement moi qu'ils en font sans
nommer ici oui
[Musique]